welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and spiderman no way home's digital
release and upcoming blu-ray features
have finally delivered on a promise many
walked out of the theater wishing we got
to see more up in the film a true
reunion between toby maguire spider-man
and willem dafoe green goblin seriously
it's like any time these two almost
shared a frame goblin said norman's on
sabbatical honey and instead just like
moped in the background with a face full
of toby's padded ass well a newly
released footage shows that these two
actually did share a moment together in
a removed fight that once you plug the
scene back into the theatrical sequence
actually gives us a fascinating new
context for the movie's final act and
what was really running through the
twisted mind of green goblin in this
film i'm gonna break it all down so
earlier in spider-man no way home when
tom holland peter parker could not bring
himself to even say norman osborne's
name after he killed aunt may toby peter
parker steps up i think i can make an
anti-serum for dr osborne
been thinking about it a long time
gotta cure all of them
right
right
i love this moment from toby mcguire
because it shows how for toby's peter
the death of norman osborne was a major
unresolved regret in his eyes it was
really the beginning of his problems it
wasn't the bite from the spider bite it
wasn't the death of uncle ben sure uncle
ben's death was big regret but in
spider-man 3 flint marco's involvement
in that incident actually helped peter
learn the right lessons from that
osborne's death however was the curse
that toby never healed from don't tell
harry
that is what poisoned his friendship
with harry osborn and sent peter on his
dark path in spider-man 3 where he lost
mj almost and lost his best friend
something that clearly still haunts the
guy
do you have a best friend too i did
he died in my arms after he tried to
kill me it was heartbreaking
and now it haunts ned this was the true
legacy of the osborne curse the wound
toby could never heal so brutal that
toby even alludes to it after goblin
stabs him you okay uh
yeah i'm gonna dump good stuff oh god
today he was referring to his fight with
harry in spider-man 3 when harry stuck
him with a dagger
now it's in this moment when these two
briefly share their only eye to eye
connection in the whole film as norman
wakes up from the goblin nightmare
it's really a beautiful moment of acting
from willem dafoe but it's a question
that he asks tom holland peter framing
it around norman realizing what he did
to may not what he just did to toby and
even when the spell sends them back to
their home realities toby's symbolic
unhealable wound continues to pain him
you're in so much pain huh i am yeah so
that brings us to the new footage that's
being released for the no way home
digital and blu-ray releases one brief
clip shows the toby version of
spider-man mask on fighting goblin both
of them on the glider another clip shows
an even more interesting part of this
starting with toby spider-man alone on
that glider then goblin leaps down on
that glider to join him and then fights
him so what was really going on here why
was it removed from the film you know
finding the hidden details here is
actually pretty fun it's not as fun to
have hidden details and things like oh
you're banking because traditional banks
have all kinds of drawbacks 35 overdraft
fees bad customer service no cash back
on debit purchases well albert is
completely different from any bank
account you have ever had albert is free
to sign up for and super easy to use
when you get paid onto your albert card
albert can get your paycheck to your
card up to two days early now exact
timing depends on your employer's
payment schedule but albert also doesn't
charge overdraft fees ever and they'll
let you advance up to 250 from your next
paycheck and pay it back with no
interest and no credit check managing
your personal finances can be hard and
stressful but albert has a team of
financial experts they call geniuses
that will look at your situation and
help you make a plan and answer any
questions if you get stuck they have an
easy to use app interface and lots of
great tools to help you save money so
click the link in the description box or
go to albert.com
rockstars to download the albert app
today that's albert.com rockstars for a
limited time when you open a checking
account and connect a qualifying direct
deposit you'll get 150 dollars and
thanks again to albert for sponsoring
this video well when you revisit the
beats of the statue of liberty battle of
this film the three peters with doc ox
help successfully cure sandman and
electro and lizard toby maguire peter
has agreement with doc andrew garfield
peter has a reunion with elektro then
doctor strange returns from the mirror
dimension and then toby's spider sense
kicks in can the spiderman come out to
play
then it all unfolds real fast goblin
swoops in with his razor bats doc ock
shields the others goblin swipes the box
doc ock grabs the glider strange lassoes
the box back goblin cuts one of doc
ock's arms and flees but leaves a
pumpkin grenade in that box boom now
throughout all this toby just kind of
watches and there really isn't a spot in
these few seconds when he could have put
on his mask and engaged goblin on the
glider and after that box explodes the
scaffolding on the statue of liberty
collapses as the shield plunges but just
to a pause point at the statue's chest
mj falls tom tries to save her and
goblin swipes him out of the way at
which point andrew saves her instead but
then the shield falls all the way to the
bottom through the rest of the
scaffolding smashing everything and it
is total madness in the falling debris
we can see toby webbing andrew doc
grabbing electro and the cloak saving
ned no sign at all for who saved mj if
andrew needed to be saved but she ends
up just running out from behind some
rubble when ned lands she's totally fine
so then after the shield falls to the
ground level and rolls partly into the
water we then see the shots of tom still
holding onto goblin's glider breaking
open the grenade chamber activating a
grenade and stuffing it back in to crash
them both on that shield for the final
throws of the fight so that moment
tracks from goblin to swiping peter when
he tried to save mj it is possible then
that something could have been cut from
the middle of this shield's collapse
from when it fell to halfway down the
statue then strange's spell exploded and
then it falls the rest of the way
sometime right before goblin swiped tom
from saving mj like maybe after goblin
cut doc ock's arm toby might have left
after him and the two could have shared
a moment on that glider and then toby
got knocked off or something but since
this new footage shows toby masked
during his fight with goblin and toby
andrew and tom were only masked in their
earlier part of this battle and then
taking them off to talk to max and to
talk to otto and then really leaving off
the masks for the rest of the film i
think his confrontation with goblin on
the glider happened earlier in the
battle when they were still struggling
with sandman and with electro and lizard
actually i think you can pinpoint the
exact second that cut happened the
moment when toby cures sandman and
actually use archive footage of thomas
hayden church from the 2007 film since
church only returned to no way home for
voiceover work toby is unmasked there
but seconds after this when we see him
he is masked again joining tom and
andrew on the statue of liberty head but
swinging in from the side despite that
moment with flint taking place inside
the statue head which would be right
behind where they now are so i think
that was where originally toby was gonna
fight with goblin on the glider who
showed up in the first part of the
battle and toby and willem were gonna
get their big to face reunion which
would mean that after he cured flint
toby would have put the mask on and then
would have collided directly with
goblin's glider but just the glider and
then after he boarded that glider goblin
would have popped down to join them and
they would have fought but why the
glider alone well because that was how
toby subdued goblin in the 2002 film
goblin impaled by his own glider goblin
already killed one person this night
with the glider as a drone spear aunt
may and now he tried to kill his peter
parker the same way now i know you might
say here whoa wait norman was teleported
to the mcu from the rainy verse before
he died that way correct but they
deliberately included a line where flint
marco told him what his fate was going
to be it was all over the news
green goblin
impaled by the glider you flew around on
and right there in willem dafoe's eyes
you can see the spark of an idea that he
could use this to kill his biggest
enemies the same way he was going to be
done in and so that would have given us
that moment between goblin and toby that
we all wanted so badly like imagine that
conversation goblin recalling the
godspeed spider-man and then toby's
saying actually i did tell harry and it
was the biggest regret of my life which
would lead to gobbin retreating for now
which is why later toby was the first
one to notice him when he returns saying
can the spider-man come out to play now
really it just seems like they cut the
scene so that goblin's delayed assault
later in the battle would come as a
bigger surprise in the second act of the
battle a way to raise the stakes and it
does it totally works but it does come
at the expense of us getting one
face-to-face reunion that we were really
hoping for hopefully we will see the
full version of the scene on the blu-ray
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at evos
subscribe to new rockstars thanks for
watching and godspeed
[Music]
you